teheran die stadt ohnehin eine dicke
smogwolke überdeckt die acht millionen
metropole irans hauptstadt im
kulturellen spagat zwischen moderne und
tradition
in teheran zwesten an einem geheimen ort
trug hamid brasserie der regisseur gilt
als erneuerer der iranischen
theaterszene seit über vier monaten
arbeitet er mit zehn frauen an seinem
neuesten stück die jungen
schauspielerinnen hinterfragen weibliche
rollenbilder und das im iran wo eine
restriktive zensurbehörde am drücker ist
ich habe noch nie wegen einschränkungen
oder unterdruck aufgehört zu arbeiten
ich will damit sagen die zensur aber für
mich noch nie ein hindernis
manchmal sind die beamten auch zu mir
gekommen um sich das stück anzuschauen
danach haben sie gesagt okay das kannst
du so zeigen zensur macht ihn
erfinderisch privatwohnungen
galerieräume oder parkhäuser als bühnen
er etabliert das geraer theater in
teheran
probenbeginn das laute liegt hamid
karsai nicht seine regieanweisungen
flüstert er lieber im stück selbst wird
seine gesellschaftskritik aber umso
deutlicher spürbar
zehn frauen sind auf der flucht jede
steckt in einer identitätskrise jede
möchte ihre vergangenheit hinter sich
lassen
erinnerungen an eine schlimme kindheit
an eine unerwiderte liebe oder an eine
missglückte schwangerschaft gemeinsam
zeichnen sie ein bild der iranischen
frau die ausbrechen will und nicht kann
es ist überall schwierig für eine frau
gefühle auszudrücken
vielleicht ist es im iran schwierig ein
bestimmtes geschlecht zu haben mich
meine frau zu sein
aber anderswo gibt es andere
schwierigkeiten dennoch die gemeinsam
entwickelten szenen zeigen das leben der
iranischen frau als realen albtraum
geprägt von einschränkungen und
leistungsdruck
ich wasche ich wasche es wird nicht
sauber ich kann vor müdigkeit nicht
schlafen
ich falle in ohnmacht die alpträume
kommen und mit ihnen die angst ich sehe
meine juden und habe wieder angst alles
ist schmutzig ich wasche ich putze
einmal zwei mal 10 mal es wird nicht
zaubern
ich will mit diesem stück auch zeigen
dass die außensicht auf den iran nicht
immer die einzig richtige ist wir sehen
heute auf der straße wie jede frau für
sich agiert und sich ihre rolle immer
mehr bewusst wird
es ist wichtig zu verstehen ein teil
ihres verhaltens ist gesellschaftliche
tradition und nicht nur unterdrückung
die meisten der darstellerinnen
studieren theaterwissenschaften oder
geschichte moderne frauen also die eine
allzu klare zuschreibung scheuen
als wir zusammen gekommen sind hatten
wir immer bedenken
wir sind zehn frauen und wollen auf
keinen fall in eine feministische
klischeebehafteten theater sparte
gedrängt werden
aber ich weiß nicht vielleicht seht ihr
das von außen einfach so es schmälert
unsere arbeit wenn wir ständig nur auf
die einschränkungen verweisen
solche vorkommnisse gibt es in jedem
land
wir möchten nicht immer anklagen und
alles mit einem etikett versehen
was ist das für ein land frauen fühlen
sich heute emanzipierter gleichzeitig
gibt es eine strenge sitten polizei das
kopftuch ist pflicht immer menschen
können hier nicht selbst entscheiden was
sie glauben oder wen sie lieben wollen
iran im sommer 2014
der imam hat in den trüben himmel
geschaut und den mond trotzdem gesehen
es wird das ende des ramadans gefeiert
hamid brasserie will uns in dieser nacht
seien teheran zeigen 315 meter über der
stadt thront die aussichtsterrasse des
milad fernsehturms bei aller pracht
die frage bleibt warum geht er nicht weg
wenn er hier doch nie ganz ohne
einschränkungen arbeiten kann
teheran ist meine liebe ich denke
theater ist hier die wichtigste
gesellschaftliche ausdrucksform mit der
kultur politik und wirtschaft
vorangebracht werden können
das theater drückt den wunsch nach einer
besseren zukunft aus das theater möchte
dass unsere fantasien fliegen
das theater will dass wir uns bewegen
zürich theaterspektakel alle
vorstellungen der theatergruppe sind
ausverkauft
die bühne ist so karg wie der übungsraum
in teheran das schweizer publikum wähnt
sich im mittleren osten
die schlichte inszenierung und das
ausdrucksstarke spiel der jungen
darstellerinnen verfehlen ihre wirkung
nicht
die hoffnung auf eine neue freiheit und
das aufbegehren gegen gesellschaftliche
konventionen erfüllen die theaterhalle
ein seltenes fenster in die iranische
gesellschaft steht offen
am epa sari versteht das stück als
fortlaufende dokumentation der
geschehnisse in seiner heimat
zürich ist der startpunkt für mich es
war mir wichtig die premiere hier zu
haben
gerade weil die zuschauer die sprache
nicht sprechen
so konnte ich sehen ob meine vision
funktioniert das stück werde ich immer
weiterentwickeln